hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Grady Frank
we're gonna watch the trailer today for
a movie starring Kevin Hart and Will
Ferrell one who a lot of people like
right now and another who has lost a lot
of credibility lately mm-hmm well hell
that's the one who lost a lot of
good-looking people love Kevin know
people do love Kevin Hart and he's funny
he is really hot I could stand it he's a
black comedian who doesn't make a lot of
like black jokes actually it would I
would still be okay with it if he did
he's blacks like him and um a lot of
black comedians that don't make him name
another one Dave Chappelle he throws the
n-word out there a lot that's true I did
see him live and he doesn't make a lot
of what people are like that he does a
lot of that okay whatever we're moving
on I still like all black comedians well
I'm not because of the black whatever
who's the Kings car man oh the Builder
wish me give us call
oh I got almost no cash just $9,000 key
I would've done the same thing if you
were white that's good to know
windows des this video the rest of fraud
boom doesn't I have faith that justice
system will exonerate me i sentence you
to ten years in a maximum-security
prison does he say ten years my life is
ruined because after 30 days I'm going
to prison
teach me how to survive in prison the
way you did tell me knowledge please
give your low economic status wait what
the perceived lack of college education
Mac okay statistically you definitely
went to prison see them all candy come
on you [ __ ] who's this session I'm
learning so much this is exactly what I
did what reason did you give him to
assume that you went to jail it was
being black you're not exactly a South
all I got to do was solo deeper I'm
gonna walk away from you master these
skills will survive interesting you
tomato face of life what does it matter
you're very cool woody doing James
sad dog a new strategy that could work
please don't sexually so may have
already too sad I go hard
listen I never defeat does it know me
your hands man beating
staying quaint man you're the wrong part
of your white boy your [ __ ] in Jersey
go back we belong car serration expert
repairs we are about to simulate a
prison join that was intense right
actually I feel fine
Romeo Oh Mia it's my game name and it's
short for mayonnaise white cuz he's
white and the other ones black ha ha ha
ha ha
but in all seriousness it looks like a
blast it looks like a lot of fun it's
it's a very well well brandy gathers her
emotions it's very simple plot yeah
but the execution looks great I'm happy
to see Will Ferrell play more of the
straight man this time yeah and not in a
gay-straight kind of way you know like
those just like I'm the street woman to
his crazy shenanigans you're kind of a
lesbian to my crazy shenanigans you
don't respond it on to my sexual
behaviors in a positive manner let's not
confuse the audience Kevin Hart is doing
this Kevin Hart thing I'm okay with
Kevin Hart always doing is Kevin Hart I
think you like it's always funny it's
[ __ ] I think the duo is a great combo
and everything about it and they really
play on it almost every one of his
movies makes fun of the fact of how are
you sure but that was the funny bit when
he was like hopping over yeah the fact
that will fare all significantly taller
than it's gonna be a good Hollywood
comedies gonna be filled with some fun
it's it's gonna be you know Kevin Hart
Will Ferrell doing their thing at the
best they can
it's cool seeing Will Ferrell like kind
of transitioning to like a Steve Martin
kind of phase where it's a little bit
more that's true
ya know C Martin's good but Will Ferrell
he's done some more dramatic work I mean
that didn't become that
but he's not some dramatic worker he's
actually really good in it it's not as
ice watching anchorman 2 the other day
again seeing him in this and like it's
much more toned down more realistic and
I'm it's cool the scene doing a comedy
like that yeah his acting maybe his
comedic style is changing it's a little
bit more dry and very realistic kind of
my favorite part was Oh baby was like
don't walk away I think there's gonna be
a lot of great improv between them too
oh there has to be well thanks guys for
something that trailer was out if you're
new to the channel you can subscribe to
the real rejects brandy has a channel
and she has started doing movie reviews
legit good movie reviews they're not as
perverted as mine which is shocking but
they're pretty good though they're
pretty good does like any flakes a lot
Indian yeah I do a lot of indie flix
so check it out Jawad Abdul you the man
Ryan oh you the man run so cool hey
here's a dirty joke so a guy went to a
bar the bartender told him I will give
you $100 if you can make my horse laugh
which he did so he said give me my money
you [ __ ] then the bartender said I
will give you $200 if you can make it
cry so he did then he said give me my
money you [ __ ]
then the bartender give the $200 and
said how did you do it
no one could not do it before the guy
said that's easy the bartender said how
you make him laugh he said that's easy I
said my dick is bigger that's is how you
make him cry I showed him I Jawad give
me a shout-out no ok so he he laughed
when he told him my dick's bigger than
yours and he's and then he whipped it
out and he started crying because it
actually was because horses are known to
have very large penises yeah I just did
a horse film like where they're not like
a porn that's what your film
yeah but it's called spirit writers
anyway they have merit writers ha ha
that sounds like important there was his
one horse that he was just sitting
a little field and he's like hey guys
and it's like this long oh wow that is
comfortable knowing the image of a horse
penis on my face is geladas got kind of
a point like when I see a horse penis
I'm like that's all I see from the horse
right now that's not I'm not any miring
the horse I'm just looking at its dick
Jawad um that's cool good name for a
dick
Jawad the music of PL + s you guys you
guys you guys you guys maybe plaids
music of plaids I I don't care to know
how so awesome reactions are priceless
well we're not gonna know for sure which
is why I subscribed I used a lot of the
ellipses thought thought thought thought
thought thought thought yes you did
the music of hope what'd you say I said
plants because plus is add plants what
our plans I don't know music applause
maybe it was just an idea
our plaids like the cushion in between
your balls in your butthole what I
thought that's like the cushion use
there to help massage it so that way it
relieves back pain I was like thinking
lumberjack look at my scar no it's for
the Gooch so they call it the Gooch
Emmanuel Martinez please give me a shout
out or I'm gonna unsubscribe just
kidding but can you please give me a
shout-out put on your next vid please
the Manuel Martinez it is not the next
video since you asked but who's your
shout out now and how dare you threaten
me that you'll unsubscribe you don't
unsubscribe I block you from the channel
that's what I do
can't fire and boom I'm going to block
him if he threatens me like if someone
says I'm breaking out for you no I'm
breaking up with you